l'humain augmenter la réalité augmentée
ça veut dire quoi en fait la réalité
augmentée est une expérience amplifie
par des hologrammes dans une usine par
exemple ces ajouts virtuel apparaissent
dans champ de vision du travailleur
grâce à des lunettes spéciales
une équipe de découverte en a fait
l'expérience
un carnet de livraison bien garnie des
avions par dizaines grâce aux chaînes de
montage automatisé le rythme de
production est soutenu
[Musique]
en marge de ses usines surdimensionné
une partie de l'assemblage se fait de
manière plutôt artisanale
le travail en tant que tel et pau si
compliqué que ça installer un boulon
installer une vie s'installe et les
choses comme ça c'est pas si complexe
c'est la séquence
le nombre d'opérations la précision
nécessaire c'est ce qui fait que ça
devient complexe
dany dumont vice président opérations
innovation technologie chez avior
produits intégrés
chez avior pas de chaîne robotisée que
des humains les pièces produits étaient
assemblés ici sont des pièces critiques
vital pour la navigabilité de l'appareil
leur précision est de l'ordre de
l'épaisseur d'un cheveu divisé par
quatre ce qu'on voulait c'est à aider
nos employés à les guider plus
rapidement et à prendre plus rapidement
comment faire le travail comment
assembler les assemblages complexes
qu'on a affaire ici
la solution plonger dans l'industrie 4.0
[Musique]
pour moi l'industrie 4.0 c'est un peu
comme le concept du mais augmenté commun
on a en aide les gens à donner plus
efficaces dans leur quotidien humain
augmente et réalité augmentée que
veulent dire ces concepts
l'art est d'augmenter si le principe de
rajouter du digital donc des images du
texte mais surtout des modèles 3d dans
la réalité je m'appelle francis dubé et
je suis le chef technologique chez die
zeit réalité augmentée c'est
l'impression d'avoir des objets virtuels
autour de nous dans notre monde physique
dips ait cette équipe allait caviar dans
la mise en place de la réalité augmentée
pour bonifier cette réalité on lui
ajoute des hologrammes ces ajouts
apparaissent dans le champ de vision
leurs produits via une lunette spéciale
[Musique]
souvent les entreprises vont utiliser
des guides son papier des pdf pour
essayer de comprendre comment faire des
procédures d'assemblage la réalité
augmentée on dit on scrap tout ça et à
la place on dit on va me présenter les
informations directement dans le champ
de vision de l'usager
cet outil conçu pour le projet boeing
sert à assembler les pièces qui
supporteront les moteurs du 737 max
c'est le premier du genre à être
assemblés en mode réalité augmentée
avec la réalité augmentée on risque
d'avoir moins besoin d' expertise
technique avancée et là ça nous permet
d'apprendre des gens de d'autres
fonctions d'autres postes pour être
capable de venir supporter les équipes
d'assemblage et de permettre de faire
des assemblages quand même assez
complexe avec des gens qui ont pas
d'expertisé en assemblage mais une
connaissance l'aéronautique
est ce qu'un journaliste qui fait un
reportage en aéronautique pourrait donc
assemblé une pièce je pense que
journaliste pour assembler une pièce
mais on va l'inspecter deux fois ok et
est-ce qu'on peut l'essayer
premièrement avec la lunette les mains
sont olives les gens peuvent travailler
librement ils sont guidés
ok ok donc je suis
ok je le vois très bien
l'employé qui travaille pas besoin
d'apprendre quels numéros doit il doit
aller chercher dans quel endroit dans
quel location la lune est le guide
exactement ça facilite énormément la
halle la charge mentale de l'employer
dans son travail quotidien pour l'aider
puis guidé là on dirait que l'oeil
pilote lapierre du pilote on pense
qu'avec la lunette la courbe
d'apprentissage aux entrées du parc 2 et
voit par trois si ça fonctionne bien on
parle de cette pièce là et on m'indique
la great augmentent est intéressante
pour les travaux jusque là le nombre de
séquences et la complexité est grande
dans merci la vie romancée de
l'expérience effectivement signé d'être
à deux pour s'assurer
donc ça va être très utile pour tout ce
qui est guide d'assemblage maintenance
inspection de pièces tout ce qui est
opérations de nouvelles machines mais ça
va être surtout pour des domaines
spécialisés donc faut vraiment qu'il ya
un certain niveau de complexité pour
qu'on voit la valeur âge
en ce moment la précision offerte par la
réalité augmentée tourne autour du cm
bientôt la symbiose avec le réel sera
totale
l'arrimage parfait sera rendue possible
grâce aux informations colligées au fil
des mois par des caméras et des capteurs
dissimulé sur la lunette
et tous et captant le vent lui permettre
d'avoir la position de la tête dans
l'espace est de capturer le mouvement
des mains et même de suivre la position
des pupilles de l'utilisateur pour être
capable de suivre son record on a besoin
de tous ces paramètres le pour générer
une image qui va être précise fictive
qui va rendre illusion convaincante une
illusion convaincante pour se départir
des guides d'assemblage c'est un peu ça
la réalité augmentée
on sait que les géants de la tête comme
google mike rostov et à pau sont en
train d'investir des milliards de
dollars pour la rendre accessible au
grand public
donc le monde pensent peut-être que si
futuriste la réalité augmentée mais
c'est vraiment maintenant ça existe
aujourd'hui c'est le moment de
s'intéresser à ce puits de voir toutes
les transformations qui vont arriver
dans les années qui s'en viennent
[Musique]